what are the areas of capacity that I
really have I don't even know what that
really means I'll break down for you and
I'll give you some tips I could put 60
points you but I'm gonna simplify and
just give you some of the points that
maybe haven't heard of before so let's
get right into a look you have to accept
a couple things here this is an example
of three different human beings each
with a different level of capacity this
person's capacity the person number 3
this person's capacity makes him right
here
he doesn't have where she doesn't have
his capacity okay this person can reach
at their maximum capacity and give
everything in life and above it beyond
everybody else in a certain industry and
they can never compete with this
person's capacity and then you have
these guys who have more talents than
other people who have more access to
resources than other people their
capacity is higher and that's okay
you're watching us right now saying Pat
I kind of don't like that what I mean
you don't like that well I feel I can be
anything in life because my mom told me
I can be anything in life your mom lied
you can't be anything in life you can't
be LeBron James you cannot be Usain Bolt
you can't that has to do with the body
let me explain what I mean by this in a
sports example and then you can
understand it for yourself red means
somebody who is an underachiever say
this is you you stay here you're an
underachiever
blue means you're an achiever you did
good you wanna achieved at the level
that you should have Green is what you
were supposed to do you did but you took
it to a whole different level and you
became an overachiever where no one
expected you to reach you reached that's
a whole different idea let me explain
again here we can talk about a guy named
Mugsy Bogues he gets drafted in the NBA
he is five three a hundred and thirty
five pounds let me say this one more
time he's five three 135 pounds he plays
14 seasons in the NBA at 5-3 135 pounds
average and eight assists a game
he is an overachiever because no one in
the history the NBA's ever been five
three
show this player ever that guy goes
right up here as an achiever
he's an overachiever let's put it over
here Shack most people would say is an
overachiever
I don't put Shack as an overachiever I
put shack as an achiever why you're 71
ok you got big hands size 24 feet
massive strong powerful you can push
everybody around Shack could have been
the greatest basketball player of all
time not one of the greatest now top 10
greatest he could have been the greatest
we've never seen a human being like that
before mr. history of sports comes in 71
320 340 pounds and he's got hops and
he's fast he could have been the
greatest offseason he put on weight
never practiced his free throws as much
as he could have been what if Shaq
practice is free-throw and started
shooting 73% instead of 59% what if Shaq
you know added another footwork during
the time he was playing he was playing
against Hakeem Olajuwon what if he went
and got a couple other footwork so what
if he did better conditioning during
offseason what if they took care of
himself
maybe Shaq could have been averaging 38
points again maybe shot could have been
known 16 rebounds he may be shot could
have been doing 71 a percent free-throw
showing what happened there
see to me he's an achiever but Mugsy
Bogues is an overachiever but even
though Mugsy Bogues is an overachiever
he'll never be a Shaq cuz shack at
achiever is still better than Mugsy
Bogues however when Mugsy Bogues goes to
sleep at night he needs to know that he
reached he's an overachiever in life in
every body in his industry respects him
that's the part